hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
and I'm pleased to announce a new thing
that I'm gonna be doing when you
purchase the order flows trader software
is you're gonna get access to a weekly
online live group training call and what
it is it's meant for people that have my
software ok so it's not going to be like
posted on to YouTube for everyone to see
it's it's mainly aimed at people traders
that then I purchased my software and
want to reach me you know maybe they got
a question about something or you know
they want to learn how to use some of
the features and it's really meant for
all range of experience you know whether
you're new to my software or that you've
been using it for a year you're welcome
to join in and again it's free it's a
resource for users of my software you
know one of the the more big complaints
I've been getting is people say oh it's
so hard to reach you it's so hard to
reach you and this is a forum where you
can come in you know you'll get access
once you purchase the software he'll
then later be sent the login information
to access this weekly live training
session so I'll be there ok it's like
it's a it's a live call with me so you
know if you've got a problem with your
machine ID or you switched computers you
need to you know you want to know how to
switch machine ID over you know I'll be
there to answer it say maybe you got
questions with the settings you know
what what do they mean and things like
that you know that that's what I'm there
for I'm there to answer those questions
and I'm also going to be talking about
you know interesting about you know
interesting trades that were in the
market you know the last few days you
know that the previous week because I'm
going to be doing this
Monday evenings I'm looking at 7 p.m.
Central Time it's 8 p.m. Eastern Time
you know which is morning in Asia and
you know if you're in Europe I apologize
it's quite late but you know these
sessions will also be recorded but
though we recorded and they're going to
be put into a special members-only
access area for users of the software
and like I said you know basically it's
a it's you know I don't say housekeeping
but you know it's everything you know
anything you want you know you want to
talk about you know say you want to show
me a chart say hey Mikey
I saw this you know what do you think of
this chart can you explain it you know
like this was this morning in the ESPYs
you know this was a great low-risk
trading opportunity right here just
after you know it's about 847 this
morning you know we got this nice
prominent point of control we came right
down to that prominent point of control
got a double bottom here then the market
rally five points so you know be talking
about you know trade setups that you
know I saw or you know trades that I had
taken and you know it sort of dissect
them but it's also there as a resource
for you to reach out to me you know a
lot of people you know what I've noticed
with traders is you know some are very
secretive they just want to keep
themselves that's fine and others want
to have someone to talk to and you know
that's fine so this I feel I feel sort
of comes in the middle you know there's
gonna be people that attend and just
watch and you know don't say anything
there's gonna be people out that want to
ask questions you know I had sort of a
test to run the other day this past
Monday and you know I had about eight
questions from people that had sent them
in so you could also send in your
questions beforehand or just ask them on
the call and you know I'll answer them
so like I said you know if you want to
reach me you know this is there I'll be
there I'll be available you know every
Monday whenever we do these sessions you
know it's a regular thing so like say
you buy the software today and you know
you want to spend a week or two getting
used to it you could just that's fine
you could come in any time you know
after you purchase the software and you
know whether it's it's the next session
or a session three weeks four weeks a
month you know twelve months down the
line you know it's there for you you
know that that's what it is it's a
resource for you to to fall back on you
know say hey hey Mike you know I'm
traveling I want to switch my machine ID
from my laptop from my desktop to my
laptop for the next two months can you
do that for me yeah I can do that to you
for you and you know I'll explain you
know some of the other you know
indicators and like I said you know it's
a lot of people you know they get the
software and they can't figure it out
you know I can't make heads or tails of
software and and you know people say
what you don't offer support well you
know I I do have guides but you know
this takes it a step further this is you
know for you to come in here for a call
say hey Mike show me what you know what
it means what this summary content means
you know what's the point of it why do
you only have Delta max Delta min Delta
volume on your chart why don't you have
you know the ask the bid kima don't you
have everything I've shown on your chart
and I'll explain why why I use it and
you know if if that's something you want
to do you can do it you know what maybe
you want to look at also a cumulative
Delta that's fine you know I'll explain
you know all the different settings on
you know the different indicators that
you may have from me and you know that's
really the whole point of it is is to
create a place where you could come you
could ask your questions to me and you
know I'll do my best to answer them for
you live you know it's not something
where you send me an email and you know
because be honest you know I get
thinking about 700 emails a day and
emails do get lost in in in it you know
it's that you know I said you know this
is where you know you'll find me each
week online live in person not somebody
else not somebody there you know not
some outsourcer that I hired to answer
questions know that that's me so I think
it's a tremendous resource but again
it's only available to users of the
order flows the trader software so you
know if you haven't signed up already if
you haven't purchased it go to order flu
can't talk go to order flows calm slash
off to die HTML and pick up the software
you know you get a lot of training you
know it's I said it's it's always it's
one thing to have software you know have
a volume footprint chart but honestly if
you don't know what you're looking at
then it's a waste of money you know it's
like I realize that you know a lot of
traders are interested in order flow but
they need honestly they need a little
hand-holding you know they need a little
guidance and that's what I'm there to
provide you know I'm not here to scam
your money as some people that are
unhappy with me you know I like to stand
up on a mountaintop and ie Mike's out
there to scam anyone you know I'm not
you know I just want you to have some
success in trading okay and I realize I
can't help everybody because at the same
time you have to want to help yourself
okay you have to want to make a change
that's why this training is only
available to users of the order flows
trader software because you know I want
you have some skin in the game you know
if I just have this
out there posted up online for free
people watch it and do nothing with it
that's why it's available for users of
my software because they've made an
investment in themselves you know they
want to learn and that's the whole point
of of having this weekly training so
that you can you know ask questions jump
into it more and find out you know the
answers to the questions that you've
been having you know a lot of people
come to me I have been trading futures
for you know five years but you know
it's it's I just can't get my head
around it but you know I know like I'm
missing something and you know I think
order flow can can help me put over the
top you know and that's what I'm here
for it is to help you get over that
hurdle
so again if you haven't got the order
flow strainer software you know pick it
up I said if you already have the order
flow trader software I'll be sending you
an email out in the next couple of days
explaining this whole weekly training
call you know I'm not gonna have the
training room because honestly you don't
having a trading room what you get is
you tend to get a lot of people in there
just sitting back so okay where do I buy
where do I sell you know I'd rather
teach you how to read the market and
understand so you can make those
decisions yourself you know it's it's
really pointless to sit here and say buy
here and then everyone goes in buys you
know if you want a red light green light
system based on order flow you know what
we're developing something but it's
gonna cost an arm and a leg
and it's not something that that people
that like a red light green light system
are gonna pay up for honestly it's it's
it's close to ten thousand dollars and
you know it was a it's an automated
trading system but you know it's it's
not gonna be available to everybody and
that said you know I don't wanna talk
about too much but again thanks for
watching this video and you know I hope
to see you in the trading training
coming up thanks bye bye